en este vídeo haremos un ejemplo en
donde calcularemos la energía interna y
también calcularemos presión volumen y
trabajo entonces sabemos que la presión
externa es 1.01 por 10 a las 5 pascales
y nuestro sistema es un globo digamos
que es un globo que contiene argón
inicialmente tenemos un volumen de 2.3
litros pero después el gas transfiere
transfiere
485 jules de energía en forma de calor a
los alrededores
alrededores
una vez que eso pasa el volumen final de
nuestro sistema es de 2.05 litros y
vamos a suponer que los moles de gas no
cambian así que la pregunta que queremos
responder es cuál es el valor de delta y
cuál es el cambio de energía interna en
nuestro sistema
para resolver esto podemos usar la
primera ley de la termodinámica que dice
que el cambio de energía interna delta
iv es igual al trabajo realizado más el
calor transferido pero antes de
sustituir los valores
me gustaría que primero nos demos una
idea de cuáles deben de ser los signos
en cada cosa porque yo creo que eso es
un poco confuso en este tipo de
problemas entonces vamos a ver en este
caso como nuestro sistema transfiere
energía a los alrededores y no al revés
q debe ser negativa porque cuando el
sistema transfiere energía a los
alrededores la energía interna disminuye
por otro lado vamos a ver el trabajo
como b 2 es menor a b1
es decir el volumen disminuyó eso
significa que los alrededores tienen que
hacer un trabajo sobre el globo para que
el volumen disminuye entonces si los
alrededores hicieron un trabajo en
nuestro sistema
ya interna aumenta y eso significa que
aquí el trabajo realizado es positivo y
miren también podemos calcular el
trabajo porque sabemos que la presión
externa es constante y el trabajo se
puede calcular como presión externa por
el cambio de volumen y ya conocemos esto
ya conocemos la presión externa el
volumen inicial y el volumen final
entonces vamos a sustituir eso tenemos
que delta y es igual a menos 485 jules
ese es el calor y tiene un signo
negativo porque el calor se transfiere a
los alrededores por eso menos 485 jules
menos aquí me faltó el signo negativo
la presión externa es 1.0 1 por 10 a las
pascal es por el cambio de volumen que
sería el volumen final es decir 2.0 5
litros
- el volumen inicial que era de 2.30
litros y en este punto podríamos decir
ok ya resolvimos todo y solo tenemos que
calcular esto en la calculadora y si eso
sería lo primero que haríamos
generalmente pero hay algo muy
importante que debemos revisar antes de
obtener el resultado y hacer una fiesta
y son las unidades
miren el calor lo tenemos en jules y
también queremos el cambio de energía
interna en jules pero de este lado
estamos calculando el trabajo y tenemos
pascales
a ver aquí tenemos jules y jules y aquí
tenemos pascal es por litros
entonces fíjense tenemos jules menos
pascal es por litros y además tenemos
que asegurarnos de que lo que sea que
estamos calculando aquí en términos de
trabajo también tenga jules como
unidades porque si no estaremos restando
dos cosas que no tienen las mismas
unidades y eso es muy malo así que
primero tenemos que hacer una conversión
de unidades cómo hacemos que los
pasteles por litro nos den jules la
forma en la que yo lo hice fue pasando
todo a las mismas unidades es decir si
queremos jules que son unidades del
sistema internacional podemos
simplificar esto usando otras unidades
del mismo sistema internacional por
ejemplo un joule es igual a un kilogramo
metro cuadrado por segundo al cuadrado
entonces un joule es igual a un
kilogramo metro cuadrado por
al cuadrado mientras que un pascal los
pascal es también son unidades
utilizadas en el sistema internacional y
si convertimos los pascales a kilogramos
metros y segundos tenemos que un pascal
es igual a un kilogramo por metro
segundo al cuadrado ahora esto nos dice
que necesitamos multiplicar esto por
unidades de volumen y por lo que sea que
lo multiplicamos nos debe de dar jules
entonces lo que necesitamos hacer es
convertir los litros a metros cúbicos si
hacemos eso tendríamos todo en términos
de kilogramos metros y segundos y así
este metro se cancela con uno de estos y
nos queda un kilogramo por metro al
cuadrado entre segundo al cuadrado en
ambos lados miren ya tenemos todo en
términos de jules bueno aunque esta no
es la única forma en la que podemos
revisar que las unidades coincidan
pudimos haberlas convertido en algo más
pero en realidad sólo necesitamos estar
seguros
que todas las unidades que usemos en
nuestra ecuación sean las mismas sobre
todo si vamos a sumar o restar y por
todo esto es que convertimos litros a
metros cúbicos así ya tenemos todo en
jules y nos queda menos 485 jules menos
1.01 por 10 a las 5 pascal es por menos
0.25 litros que es el cambio de volumen
que al final resulta negativo porque el
volumen disminuye y después vamos a
agregar algo más para convertir los
litros a metros cúbicos un litro es
igual a 10 a la menos 3 metros cúbicos
así se cancelan los litros y pascal es
por metros cuadrados
nos dan jules así que del tau el cambio
de energía interna es igual a menos 485
jules y al sustituir esto en la
calculadora para calcular el trabajo
obtenemos más 25 puntos
25 jules y al sumar el calor y el
trabajo obtenemos que el cambio de
energía interna para este proceso es de
menos 460 jules ok entonces los puntos
clave a recordar en este tipo de
problemas son revisar los signos para
trabajo y calor y también verificar que
todas las unidades sean las mismas